how do doctors put these on so smooth
like this is hard except this is a me
name these are my ten essential things
today will be caring for these ten
essential things with rubber band
clothes because they're very essential
and I care about my things first up is
now I wear Julie just because it makes
me feel a bit more confident this is my
favorite ring that I got it was like the
first purchase I made once I got a
little more money in my pocket this is
my grill I only wear this when I like go
to a party or I'm with my friends this
is usually this is nice this is really
nice these are like my favorite chains
both of these are my parents when they
were like 2021 or whatever now very
close to my parents me and my parents
love each other this is my hard drive
see OPN is basically just my brand and
clothing line that a lot of like fans
purchase as well all the pieces of
clothing that I designed for my like
company and like all my music anything
pretty much important to me that can be
virtually stored I have a backup of this
at home
in case one yard tried to steal this
from me there's probably like 100 one of
these songs in this thing to be honest I
keep them stored in here when I'm having
some writer's block I kind of just go
back to this hard drive and listen to
some of the songs that I wrote there's
no like same path that I'd take to make
a song like this it's always happens and
I'm very random late you know I have a
beat first or we make the beat to a song
I already wrote it's kind of like a very
like care of this kind of process not
kiss and a negative wait look here this
in a way that
kind of that things happen to me they
have been a nothing's flourish the way
they should these are my eyeglasses
they are Warby Parker I basically buy
about like ten of these same pairs of
glasses I lose things a lot these just
look okay on me I feel like I look like
a nerd I need contacts
I'm very blind the cameras blurry to me
now so when I'm like performing the
reason I don't work glass is because of
course you can't really like jump around
with glasses but also I can't see you
[ __ ] so it's like great I'm not
that nervous my dad sent me an email
when I was on tour just like why are you
jumping into crowds that's so unsafe
these people barely know who you are how
can you trust them yeah my dad cares for
me this is my home hide when I'm making
news on and no one's heard yet I just
put in my iTunes when I wake up the next
morning after not hearing it for a while
and just tell Siri hey Siri play this
the sound quality of this thing is
really cool Apple doesn't pay me to
market this I've been doing this because
this actually sounds like pretty good
this is actually not my home pod the
good people I did cube brought this for
me because my home pod was stolen last
night at our Airbnb so to the people
that stole our home pod [ __ ] you but
this is all good material things aren't
that important but when they're
essential they're essential you see that
this is my favorite perfume because I
think men's cologne smells very strong
and doesn't smell that good so I wear
women's perfume because dudes pass me
and they're like damn bro kind of kind
of Cologne of that like it's perfume
they feel like insecure and weird about
it but then they asked me for the name
and then go get it so you know we're
changing gender norms out here
show me you Vuitton I'm not a pronounce
this mill [ __ ] fie fo fum
it's just some cool [ __ ] that smells
really good this is my pouch to go you
have pouch that I got when I was in
Mexico you're just recording music out
there pouches are pretty announced what
all the kids are doing normally I keep
like my wallet on some chapstick because
mothers always be Chad only something's
wrong with fathers genetically I hate
carrying things in my pocket that's
literally why I have this next is my
wallet this is going out as well I
really like just go yard in general I
think like the printing is really cool
it's super consistent nothing ever
changes and I like very simple designs
and I like cardholder while it's just
because I hate fat ass while this that
you have to like stuff in the back of
your ass like that [ __ ] just sucks one
thing that I have in this [ __ ] wallet
is an amazing thing I lose my wallet a
lot I have the tiles this is mat
essential whoa I lose my wallet all the
time and I love my wallet this is
something very essential to me so this
is an essential piece of my wallet which
is essential to me which is essential to
my life this is my Kiehl's moisturizes
it just makes you look shiny and clean
and not burning
so anything that makes me like not about
me it is always a plus I can't walk out
the house in my face looking dry because
nobody likes to ask you face well I have
a youtube channel all about my routine
and makeup tutorials if you want to go
check it out that's a joke I don't have
any of that
these are some of my favorite new
sneakers they're just like I I always
think you should be wearing a piece of
clothing or a pair of shoes that you
designed or your friend design that
represents something you believe in
so yeah this is Cantu loyal which is the
oil I spray my hair a lot it just smells
really really good
I have a song about it when I live a
very true life I comb the things I talk
about these are rubber bands that I wear
for my hair to tie them into these
little things almost all pigtails what
everyone's going if I didn't tie my hair
you think I just got out of it you know
it's been fun it's been a great day hope
you go home and learn a lot from this
and tell your friends 1.5 bye thank you
[Music]